la culture geek s'assume pleinement
comme des montres le phénomène des
comicon venu maintenant dans des
dizaines de villes dans le monde
montréal l'événement attire plus de 60
et le visiteur qui paie entre 69 et 229
dollars ico pour entrer au palais des
congrès le comic-con de montréal avait
pourtant débuté modestement en a
commencé avec deux mille personnes à
place bonaventure
je pense après la deuxième ou de
troisième édition on a en avait trop de
monde puis on est rendus contre le
palais au complet ça fait cinq ou six à
c'est le comic-con de san diego qui a
enregistré la marque de commerce en 2006
bioquébec l'organisation est une entité
indépendante qui organise les comicon de
montréal québec ottawa et bientôt celui
de laval pour plusieurs commerçants
cette clientèle nicher est une affaire
en or
nous nos clientèles cibles ses rangs les
joies d'un grand la nature mais ici
tellement geek qui sont les nouveaux
joueurs potentiels qu'on va les chercher
c'est vraiment pour ça qu'on est là
c'est un des meilleurs événements qu'on
a à montréal et présence de vedettes est
une marque de commerce du comicon
certains acteurs parfois presqu'oublié
peuvent encore gagner leur vie rien qu'à
faire le circuit des comics own le
public est gagné d avance
et puis jusqu'à une centaine de dollars
pour une photo avec un acteur fétiche
je pense que les gens dans les festivals
où viennent voir spécifiquement des
films où viennent voir un acteur à qui
on remet un prix en comic-con c'est du
pur qui ont encore fait mais la
compétition pour être serré les grands
noms est féroce et coûteuse entre de
nombreux comme icône à se dire comme ok
on veut la jouer à montréal on la met
peut-être un autre formation à nos
villes comme on dire mais on va lui
donner plus alors c'est dur c'est comme
si comme citibank un festival de musique
le filon n'est pas sur le point de se
tarir que jamais tout le monde veut être
super héros simspon marsolais radio
canada montréal